daraufhin schlug meine liebe freunde ich
bin und formale halb das heutige video
denn in spielen endlich mal wieder
henry's dikmen die richtigen es in der
luxus noch was das ist denn dadurch
haben früher extrem viele leute meinen
kanal überhaupt erst mal gefunden und
seit einigen wochen gibt es nun auch
henrys tritt nicht nur als lustiges
kurzes browserspiele sondern als
richtiges computerspiel und das wird vor
ein paar wochen raus gebracht von daher
dachte ich man sagt man dann einfach mal
bevor wir das allerdings von meiner
lieben freude hört schon die
weihnachtsmusik hätten an ich hab
natürlich meinen playmobil hat wenn es
keine namen staat die spannung steigt
zumindest nicht bindend
ich würde allerdings sagen wir starten
jetzt rein im henry widmen
ich habe mir neues headset gekauft aber
hatte nur geld für die hälfte mit
deswegen habe ich einfach keine bank
mitten in der wüste und henry muss über
die laser luca nehmen wir natürlich die
richtigen oli ziehen der lose wissen
wahrscheinlich noch dass ich den teil
schon mal gespielt habe
das liegt daran dass man um das neue
level zu spielen die alten teile noch
mal kurz durch spielen muss ich habe
allerdings komplett vergessen wie ich
das gemacht habe von den versuchen was
zusammen rauszufinden deshalb schon
jahre her
ich würde sagen wir ihnen einfach mal
das geld also wir versteckten uns und
verkleiden uns so wir tun so als wären
wir ein geldbeutel und 9
ja
haben wir dann jetzt leider deutlich
geschafft soll ich bin jetzt im
gefängnis weil ich ja einbrechen wollten
dabei erwischt wurde von daher müssen
wir aus dem gefängnis ausbrechen
[Applaus]
genau das geräusch der zahlen als bei
mir letztens im cern gemacht einen
teleporter anbindung wir haben noch
einen energy-drink eine feile und ein
rock
das ist das was
warum bin ich denn so schlecht sprich
skonti new york testimony auf einmal
sind wir froh gericht also wir müssen
jetzt den richter davon überzeugen dass
wir gar nicht in die bank einbrechen
wollten sondern nur schlafen wollten in
dem geld sagt vor der bank mitten in der
wüste das wird jetzt relativ easy
wahrscheinlich und daher klicke ich
jetzt einfach mal auf den geldsack drauf
endlich seinen rollen als freunde findet
henry steegmans
sehr gut nicht schuldig wir kommen raus
aus dem knast und da sind wieder frei
welt sie jetzt müssen wir vom
bürgermeister die sind ja man klauen
das ist das museum in dem sich der
diamant befindet wir können uns entweder
langsam rein schleichen oder mit einem
knall rein
jetzt liegt mir aber wir machen das ganz
entspannt leute nehmen wir ihnen hier
auch jetzt haben wir sechs verschiedene
möglichkeiten man wenn ich mich nummer
an von paar jahre erinnern könnte wie
ich das da gemacht haben wir nehmen
einfach mal dieses ding was ich nicht
aussprechen
[Musik]
ich würde irgendwann wird das
funktionieren also wir klicken darauf
werden jetzt zu liquid und können da
unten nicht
da war ja klar ist es nicht funktioniert
dann würde ich sagen jetzt einfach mal
die ngn graffiti cap wir können nämlich
jetzt einfach hoch fliegen und auf das
dach drauf
die hätte ich glaub ich als allerletztes
geschafft mit dem privat also wir müssen
jetzt auf zeit haben will
warum lassen wir doch die zeit mit dem
ertrag bringen als wenn er die also
wieder auf zeit dann nehmen wir einfach
die waffe
ich weiß aber nicht ob
luca wenn die bombe schon nicht
funktioniert wenn die wasser stay
funktionieren dann nicht mal das
flugzeug soll das alles haben wir nicht
mehr
jetzt laufen nach dem krieg vorbei ist
genau so läuft wie ich es immer dann
wenn er die augen kurz zu machen es wird
allah wir sind warum
[Musik]
jetzt mit dem pilz gemacht dass er
relativ gut geklappt
[Musik]
ich kann mich erinnern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sollen jetzt entscheiden was da gemacht
wie in die materie satelliten dpa alles
klar
das sieht auf jeden fall am
ungefährlichsten
das
spiel es dann jetzt auch abgestürzt
zu hindern uns zu diesem verdammten
satelliten entschieden von daher würde
ich sagen nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal
das ding
ich weiß aber wieder nicht ob ich damit
richtig liegen
ich habe ein bisschen schön
wer sich nicht so freundlich aus
wir haben es geschafft haben wir den
diamanten oder sieht ja nicht gleich am
straßenrand oder so ja warum soll denn
später irgendwie flugzeug so gibt es
eine vorgeschichte und erhält also ich
muss wohl irgendwie rüber zu den anderen
flugzeug und ich weiß nicht mehr wie wir
das gemacht habe aber ich glaube dass
mal was ganz verrücktes damals gesagt
keinen tollen aber ich weiß leider
nehmen wir den laser den stuhl oder den
froster ich würde sagen einfach mal den
laser
weil laser luca so abgeht der laser und
die musst du dann noch drehen dann
vertraue mir jetzt mal auf den stuhl
ich weiß nicht was damit passieren soll
besitzt jetzt einem stuhl bleibe deshalb
wirklich geklappt mit dem stuhl sucht
nach einem typen in einem plastikball
und da schmeißen oder maus schnell
schnell
ja
hätte ich auch selbst drauf kommen
können denn entscheidend ist dass wir
hier sind echt gut es geht weiter wir
laufen den typen hinterher der eine
fette goldkette hat und er macht hinter
uns die türen so wie schnell muss man
sich denn hier entscheiden also jetzt
ganz schnell luca wir nehmen die metal
fans
das gebiet
nicht existent ist so jetzt wieder ganz
ganz schnell boden das spiel ist mir so
ähnlich aufnehmen
jetzt ist das hier so assassin's creed
mäßig oder was auch immer ifab ist gut
geklappt da nehmen jetzt einfach mal den
kleider und versuchen darüber zu kleiner
was wird hundertprozentig auch nicht
klappt wir haben ihn wir haben ihn macht
das tor auf ok wir müssen den typen
jetzt noch irgendwie auf den helikopter
von uns befördern von daher will ich
sagen wenn man konnte mir nicht
vorstellen dass das klappt
ich glaube wir haben ja wir haben wir
haben es leute ich noch nicht so schnell
lesen
meine damen und herren wir haben nun
heute vier der sechs episoden
abgeschlossen wenn ich die letzten
beiden als episode 5 und die ganz neue
episode 6 in einer woche eventuellen auf
einem kanal hier spielen soll dallas
einen daumen runter wie die hühner
stationen in die kommentare und außerdem
gibt es anders und meinen dick und doof
podcast nun täglich in der
weihnachtszeit auf spotify hätten
[Musik]